hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
ein total schokoladige und sehr
festliches schichte sehr und zwar ist
das ein ferrero rocher schicht dessert
die einzelnen schichten bestehen aus
leckerem roche brownies einer
schokoladencreme und einer haselnuss
schokosoße ich will euch gerne lange auf
die folter spannen wir starten jetzt
zuallererst mit den roche brownies wir
benötigen nutella gemahlene haselnüsse
und eier
ja ihr habt richtig gehört wir brauchen
nur drei zutaten für unsere roche
brownies zuallererst geben wir dem
teller
zusammen mit den eiern in eine schüssel
und verrühren das ganze miteinander
sobald die nutella eimasse schön glatt
gerührt wurde geben wir die gemahlenen
haselnuss kerne mit dazu die findet ihr
bereits fertig gekauft gemahlen und
gerüstet und das rühren wir jetzt auch
noch ein und dann ist unser leckerer
brownie teig auch schon fertig
die form in der sie auspackt ist
vollkommen egal denn wir werden das
später sowieso alles in kleine stücke
schneiden
ich habe hier meine 18 cm springform
genommen fülle den tag hinein und dann
wird das ganze gebacken bei 180 grad
ober und unterhitze für 23 bis 25
minuten
unser brownie darf jetzt vollständig
auskühlen und in der zwischenzeit zeige
ich euch die zutaten für die schokocreme
wir benötigen kalte schlagsahne
mascarpone nutella seiner fahrt und
bacau
zuallererst wird die kalte schlagsahne
zusammen mit dem sommerbad mit unserem
handrührgerät komplett steif geschlagen
ganz wichtig ist es dass die sahne ganz
frisch aus dem kühlschrank kommt also
lasst sie auch nicht fünf minuten auf
zimmertemperatur stehen sie muss eiskalt
sein
die auf geschlagene sahne kommt jetzt
ganz kurz in den kühlschrank und ich
zeige euch was wir mit den restlichen
zutaten machen
in einer separaten schüssel wird die
mascarpone zusammen mit der nutella
richtig schön gemixt
sobald sich das ganze richtig schön
verbunden hat und zu einer einheitlichen
masse geworden ist nehmen wir unsere
sahne aus dem kühlschrank und heben das
ganze unter
damit für eine mutige konsistenz
erhalten gibt ihr das mit ganz viel
liebe mit eurem teig darunter
am besten macht ihr das in zwei bis drei
schritten ich habe es auch so gemacht
es hat wunderbar funktioniert damit das
ganze jetzt aber noch schokoladiger webt
kommt unser bacau zum einsatz
den gehen wir mit hilfe eines siebs noch
darüber und heben das auch vorsichtig
unter
die leckeren schoko creme ist auch schon
fertig und kommt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
für unsere haselnuss schokosoße
benötigen wir schlagsahne puderzucker
kakao und gehackte und gerösteten
haselnüssen
wir führen jetzt ganz einfach
puderzucker und bacau miteinander und
geben dann vorsichtig die sahne mit dazu
sobald wir das dann verrührt haben
erhalten nur unsere blitz schokosoße
übrigens anders als bei unserer
schokocreme darf die sahne hier ruhig
lauwarm sein so lässt sich das ganze
viel besser miteinander verrühren und
die schokoladensauce sieht so schon
richtig lecker aus aber wir machen hier
ein roche geschichtlich sehr und deshalb
dürfen gehackte haselnüsse nicht fehlen
die haselnuss schokosoße ist somit auch
schon fertig und der spaßige teil
beginnt wir können unser dessert endlich
schichten den komplett abgekühlten
brownie schneiden wir jetzt in stücke
wie ihr das macht ist vollkommen euch
überlassen ich rate euch aber schneidet
einfach kleine vierecke aus
das schwierigste an diesem rezept ist
übrigens dass man einfach wieder stehen
muss und die braun ist nicht so schon
vernascht wir können jetzt schichten und
das ist auch wieder total euch
überlassen
ich habe das jetzt so gehandhabt ich
starte mit der schokosoße und gäbe dann
die brownies darauf
für die optik gebe ich darüber nochmal
etwas schokosoße und startet dann mit
den leckeren schoko creme die
schokocreme habe ich mir in einen
spritzbeutel gefüllt so kann man das
ganze einfacher befüllen das sieht auch
schöne aus und jetzt macht ihr so weiter
bis ein riesengroßes glas komplett
gefüllt ist
für den abschluss gebe ich auf die
schokocreme noch mal von der schokoladen
haselnuss soße drauf verstreicht das bis
zum rand und dekoriert das ganze dann
noch mit back ako profis
fertig ist unser ferrero rocher schicht
ist sehr und ich glaube ich habe in
meinem leben noch nie so etwas
schokolade ist gegessen
ihr könnt es gerne nachmachen schreibt
mir dann euer feedback oder markiert
mich unter euren bildern mit dem hashtag
kirche sketchen auch instagram ich bin
sehr gespannt was ihr davon haltet
alle genauen informationen und die
zutaten sowie die mengenangaben findet
ihr unten in meiner infobox und ich
freue mich wenn ihr mir ein abo dallas
damit ihr auch keines meiner videos mehr
verpasst bis zum nächsten mal tschüss